valérie horrible pour la rédaction de tv
film va me rejoindre pour ce point sur
l'environnement comme chaque mardi
d'abord une pétition je vous le disais
en titre contre la production
d'agrocarburants industriels une
pétition proposée par la maison de
l'environnement par artisans du monde
pardon à la maison de l'environnement
c'est un maniement crise alimentaire
exploitation des populations des pays du
sud déforestation et augmentation de
l'effet de serre samedi dernier dans les
locaux de la maison de l'environnement
l'association artisans du monde
souhaitait alerter sur les dangers liés
au développement des agrocarburants
industriels à travers la pétition la fin
pour un plein un milliard d'êtres
humains qui souffrent de la faim alors
que les durées de quoi selon les études
de la fao y aurait de quoi nourrir toute
la planète donc ils vraiment des
dysfonctionnements au niveau du commerce
international au niveau des politiques
agricoles et donc c'est tout ça qu'on
essaye de sensibiliser de faire
comprendre aux gens des terres agricoles
confisqué qui ne servent plus à nourrir
les populations mais bien à faire rouler
nos voitures sur les panneaux les
phrases chocs accompagne l'exposition
pour mieux réveiller les consciences
je suis sensible au problème de la faim
dans le monde
et puis quand je vois ces inégalités
criantes entre les populations du nord
du sud le gaspillage qui pourrait
l'avoir d'exploitation des pays du sud
se tiendrait volts et j'aimerais bien
que tout le monde est cette sensibilité
plus en plus importantes à faire pousser
des céréales ou des choses pour
simplement l'essence des voitures sur ça
mais et tout les peuples meurent de faim
derrière ça hallucinant
j'ai vu ça sur internet je me suis dit
je veux y aller absolument pour signer
les pétitions
je pense qu'il faut sensibiliser et
c'est vrai que c'est bien de voir ce
genre de manifestation quand même 2
d'exposition
parce que ça peut être ça va dans le bon
sens mais je compte d'ailleurs j'ai
signé cette pétition
samedi dernier douze signatures ont été
récoltées
la pétition restent ouvertes à la maison
de l'environnement sur internet et dans
les boutiques d'artisans du monde
jusqu'au 30 novembre
produire des aliments pour faire du
carburant est ce que c'est une bonne
idée ou pas est-ce que c'est une
possibilité de reconversion comment vous
voyez 7,7 cette idée nous très
simplement au niveau de l'agriculture on
est là pour nourrir la population je
crois c'est notre base et je crois qu'à
après à côté des nouvelles technologies
on peut tout imaginer
je crois qu'aujourd'hui la vie culture
peut être bien nourrir la planète
nourrir ses habitants
mais je crois qu'il ya un point
aujourd'hui c'est que tous les jours on
perd de la surface avec des routes avec
des ronds points avec des des
constructions industrielles et ça on en
fait pas du tout état dont je crois
c'est ça qui est important aujourd'hui
c'est l'espace il faut qu'on garde les
spas je crois c'est 26 m² par seconde
qui s'en va du territoire choisi un
département français par an qui
disparaît
merci jean claude guénin d'être revenue
sur ce plateau président de l'union des
producteurs de fruits et légumes en ile
de france merci à vous et valérie vous
nous avez donc rejoint sur ce plateau
avec un nouvel invité on va parler de
champignons absolument c'est la saison
des champignons actuellement alors elle
touche bien sera sa femme on est encore
au coeur de la saison et nous recevons
un mycologue pour nous donner les bons
enseignements pour les champignons
etienne varney vice-président de
l'association des naturalistes des
yvelines est responsable de la mycologie
bonsoir merci de nous avoir rejoints sur
ce plateau alors je rappelle que la
mycologie est une science étudiants les
champignons donc été de vernet vous êtes
responsable de la mycologie
nous allons tout d'abord présenté cette
association et ses diverses activités
l'association donné à thuès discipline
en ce moment des activités
essentiellement tourné autour des
champignons c'est la pleine saison on en
a également des sortes d sorti au
printemps dernier thé et en hiver c'est
plus les oiseaux l'ornithologie et au
printemps on a des sorties également
botanique d'accord alors toujours des
fleurs donc alors nous n'allons pas les
champignons que l'on trouve actuellement
dans les forêts des yvelines où est ce
que on est sur son plateau
les gallois ont déjà la conversion sur
sont pas toujours les temps ça se fête
aussi comme prévu on n'a pas l'habitude
ben justement alors faites-nous le tour
de ce que vous nous avez apporté si on
avait une multitudes cela ces quelques
champignons qui ont été ramassés je
dirais en forêt de rambouillet également
en forêt de fo se repose
on trouve dans toutes nos forêts
actuellement friendly les autres pas mal
de champignons ans du plus petit au plus
grand voici des petites politique le
plus pâti choisit pas son corps à zoomer
jusqu'à lui mais c'est le plus petit
mais effectivement à 6 presque c'était
celui ci s'appelle le coc libye
filiforme et ça se mange savoir parce
qu'il ya plus de 2 d'espèces non
comestibles comestibles oui beaucoup de
champignons qui sont qui sont qui n'ont
qu'un intérêt comment dire gastronomique
et il y en a peut-être une cinquantaine
de centaines qui ont entraînement un
intérêt gastronomique
celui ci le pied bleu et qui en a un
certain nombre une dizaine ou une qui
sont mortels depuis d'autres qui sont
toxiques là comment peut-on distinguer
les champignons comestibles des non
comestible je pars n'y a pas un critère
qui dira l'odeur la couleur etc
qui va dire un champignon est comestible
ou un champignon est toxique
il faut il faut les connaître je dirais
on prend ce bol est un beau bébé ou les
gens disent tous les mollets sont bons
c'est faux je dirais on a des tubes
il ya un certain nombre de bolets qui
sont toxiques et celui ci celui ci est
comestible c'est le bol et mes trois
enfants
j'ai rapporté des spécimens de mon
jardin dans l'assignation
j'ai le même ici sellal a remis leur
couleur de miel
donc ça pousse sur les souches sur le
bois mort enterré sur dans les pelouses
et c'est un champignon très courant qui
parasitent les dirait les arbres ou qui
pousse sur le bois mort c'est un
champignon qu'il faut éviter de manger
dans les anciens livres il est cité
comme comestible mais je le recommande
pas donc il faut vraiment faire acte de
prudence est plutôt allé cueillir ces
champignons lors d'une balade en forêt
avec un guide une association le terrain
est important pour les connaître je
dirais
les livres ne suffisent pas toujours
pour appréhender un champignon crs si on
prend des champignons comme ça ils
paraissent ressemblant mais ça n'a rien
à voir quelles sont les conséquences
parce que les conséquences peuvent être
dramatiques
si on se tombe de jean bignon le
certaines sartène à manille l'amanite
phalloïde qui est verte ou blanche
certaines petites lépiote sont mortelles
et si on en commet dire si on ne meurt
pas on peut avoir des séquelles
importantes effectivement perdre perdre
un ou
c'est une gestion bien encadré il faut
vraiment flatteur on a un message de
prudence je dirais pour alors nous vous
avons suivi lors de votre dernière
excursion en forêt de rambouillet et
donc nous allons voir comment se déroule
une cueillette aux champignons armée de
bottes de bâton de l'indispensable
paniers en osier et de couteaux ils
étaient une vingtaine à l'afub ce matin
là au carrefour des bourbiers en forêt
de rambouillet l'objet de ces intenses
recherches étaient là tapi à l'abri des
feuillus le champignon vous connaissez
ça c'est une amanite on amanites qui a
une volt à la base donc à manier deux
fauves la manif triaire qui est
comestible cuite bureau
l'allemagne et rougissante est meilleur
au programme pied de mouton chanterelles
en tube amanites fauves et autres
l'acteur ait reçu de tout poil on
indique aux personnes un itinéraire et
ils viennent à chaque fois tu le trouves
un champignon intéressant ils viennent
et pillant leurs leur explique pourquoi
s'est-elle champignons trier répertorier
classer ce matin là nos passionnés
trouveront pas moins de 70 sortes de
champignons ces derniers peuvent être
mam launay déroulé visqueux velouté mais
il y a plus d'espèces non comestibles
comestibles alors méfiance
et mieux vaut se fier aux experts chaque
fois j'apprends voir connaître deux
prochains vie d'une puce et puis c'est
minable
alors là ils sont absolument pas
comestibles ou l'ennui le champignon a
justement que j'essaye de regarder pour
les regarder à nouveau livré pour la
première lettre edison j'aime bien
déterminée chercher comment fêter avec
des plantes chercher à savoir ce que
c'est connaître leur nom puis bien sûr
de temps en temps on trouve qu'ils sont
bons à manger et après on entre dans nos
assiettes extraordinaire comme certaines
espèces telles que cette sorte de petits
calculs
mais il s'agit bien d'un champignon
petit corail call auxerre puisque les
pouces sous les pins non comestibles
celui ci alors quelles sortes de
champignons trouve-t-on actuellement
dans les forêts yvelinoise des pensions
on est sous les feux ue sous les
conifères
là on est sous les pins sylvestres on
trouvera j'irai vous pouvez trouver des
bébés on peut trouver j'ai vu des
différentes ammonites on peut toutes
sortes de reçus et sous les feuilles on
peut trouver en ce moment pas mal de
scènes de la saison de la cueillette des
champignons touche à sa fin mais la
prochaine sortie est déjà organisée pour
5 10 10 novembre dans la forêt de bois
d'arcy
alors on parle donc de champignons ce
soir dans le 7-8 ils sont venus jusqu'à
nous sur ce plateau quels sont les bons
coins on peut tomber trouver ces
champignons
est ce que vous allez nous dire oui ou
non qui sont les bons coins
les gens vous ne le dirai pas les cèpes
on peut en trouver
j'irai au mois d'octobre alors ça c'est
ressembler ou sous les chênes switcher
chénier il ya ce que des endroits précis
dans le département c'est intéressant de
connaître les codes et les arbres et
je dirais c'est un petit peu je dirais
mon mandat c'est de voir l'écologie des
champignons et de pouvoir justement voir
dans quel milieu on peut trouver
tell tale champignons mais c'est un
endroit du département plus qu'un autre
décès bonjour ring dès les girolles et
sont rares par contre les cèpes de
bordeaux on peut vous montrer des coins
parce qu on en trouve peu partout avec
donc est-ce que vous donnez lors de ses
recettes on l'a pas vu dans le sujet
mais ce que vous donnez des conseils
pour cuisiner à la halle à la fin de la
cueillette de champignons dits d'abord
les cuisines et assez vite parce que les
champignons ne se garde pas donc il faut
les cuisines et le jour même ou le
lendemain et je dirais en faisant
revenir de pour qu'ils perdent l'euro
parce qu'un champignon beaucoup d'eau et
après les mettre dans un corps gras avec
d'échalotes et autres condiments les
vagues champignons préféré ne jamais
bien amaury ont printemps mais il
maintient c'est possible vous ne
prononcez pas d'accord on va demander
aux saint quentinois aux yvelinois ce
qu'ils en pensent cette question quel
est votre champignons préféré la
question du jour je mange pas
champignons la girolle celle qui est
jaune savait sa commune vient donc dans
une comète la girolle gustativement
c'est un très bon champignon et ça se
prépare
assez facilement dans
dans plusieurs recettes on peut
également les faire au vinaigre comme
des comme des condiments pour manger de
la viande blanche et cc c'est délicieux
ad c'est parce que je suis originaire de
bordeaux et que j'avais l'habitude
d'aller l'étude y avait ma grand-mère
free lie au persil avec des pâtes tout
simplement pas taille qu'un tout petit
peu de crème fraîche ail persil on en
trouve un peu par ici dans le wall les
petits champignons de paris qu'on
appelle c'est une bonne question
les chanterelles les cèpes
moi j'ai beaucoup de champignons j'aime
bien champignons chinois viennent tous
les champignons en fait à l'odeur le la
consistance aussi pour les champignons
chinois mais d'autres choses c'est le
meilleur
les voix et les couleurs voilà mes
champignons et donc il y à des
champignons que l'on peut trouver du
côté de mantes-la-jolie et d'enlever que
ça met plus en été ce sont les truffes
là tout était alors tout était qu'on
peut trouver jusqu'à jusqu'à noël qui
qui poussent sous les noisetiers et sous
les chênes m noire ou blanche
c'est une truffe qui est noir à
l'extérieur et blanche à l'intérieur car
les alors je rappelle malgré tout que il
est inutile aujourd'hui de se tourner
vers les pharmaciens pour savoir si le
shopping ou et comestibles ou pas c'est
ce que nous faisions jadis pourtant
peut-être que certains connaissent
s'intéresse aux champignons
mais de toute façon les pharmaciens
seront prudents et diront qui s'y
connaissent ou pas très bien donc je
rappelle quand même les dates des
prochaines sorties
donc c'est samedi prochain
dans la forêt de bois d'arcy les
dimanches 18 dans la forêt domaniale de
ben voila vous remercie pour ses bons
conseils valent et les deux autres
informations environnement oui
absolument wilfried un atelier
économique sociale et solidaire se
prépare à la maison de l'environnement
comment diversifier ses sources de
financement dans le cadre de cette
économie et notamment pour les
associations
un atelier rencontre sur ce thème est
organisée le 14 novembre de 14h à 20h
par la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin l'objectif de cet atelier
est de permettre à tous de bénéficier de
l'expérience de chacun et d'ouvrir des
pistes sur d'autres sources de
financement autres rendez-vous un débat
autour de la zambie à magny les hameaux
on avait parlé d'ailleurs sur ce plateau
oui la maison de l'environnement encore
et toujours propose la projection d'un
film zombie à qui profite le cuivre
suivie d'un débat sur la principale mine
de cuivre de mopani dans ce pays une
mine qui entraîne une plume pollution un
très dangereuse contre laquelle les
habitants se battent aujourd'hui
ce film permet de mieux comprendre le
processus de pillage de matière première
d'un pays du sud par multinationales qui
délocalisent artificiellement ses
bénéfices dans les paradis fiscaux qui
depuis 2009 qim savons où ils fouillent
n'existe plus les paradis fiscaux sont
pas seulement ça n'existe plus voilà
donc la projection et le débat auront
lieu le samedi 17 novembre
ce film a reçu le prix albert londres
audiovisuel en 2012 c'est à la maison de
l'environnement
merci les valeurs et on retrouve la
semaine prochaine sur ce plateau merci à
votre invité on va rester dans les
champignons encore quelques instants
avant de parler politique avec la visite
de la champignonnière de montesson c'est
ici dans les yvelines que l'on produise
ses fameux champignon de paris
je mange pas le champignon la girolle
celle qui est jaune s'accommode bien
voilà alors pendant tout le monde va
venir s'installer sur ce plateau on va
retrouver dès à présent ce bon sujet
cette visite de la champignonnière de
montesson si le sujet est prêt si le
sujet n'est pas prêt alors je vous
propose une petite virgule le face à
face on va parler politique dès à
présent sans transition